[Musique]
d'abord la pulsation le battement de
coeur de la musique cloche cambou
maracas
petit à petit les enfants finissent par
faire émerger une polyrythmie sous la
conduite patiente et bienveillante de
leurs deux invités béninois dans la
salle voisine ont chanté dans plusieurs
langues est un hymne à la vie et à la
joie
c'est le message tout simple de cette
chanson pour danser joyeux c'est ton
avis n'avait été créé pour être joyeux
alors vous l'avez chanter en français ou
dans une autre du ruban et en europe à
quelques pas tu peux être musicien et
peut ne pas avoir le don d'apprendre
nous sommes très contents parce que on
l'a appris comment il faut aimer les
enfants comment il faut les aborder pour
que ce que tu voulais reprendre pour
qu'il puisse vite saisi ce que tu l'aies
depuis plus de 20 ans les écoles de
travail et de matour bénéficie d'un
travail de fond mené par l'association
village solidaire régulièrement
celle ci invite des artistes a rencontré
les enfants pour des moments de
transmission et de partage
cette année c'est donc la fanfare
béninoise au light and qui est des
choses ce qui nous a intéressé dans leur
projet c'est qu'il était capable
d'animer des ateliers autour des
percussions bien sûr et puis aussi de la
danse du chant
je sais qu'ils ont fait aussi de la
cuisine et ils vont faire de la cuisine
dans d'autres classes et c'était cette
ouverture un peu plus globale qui nous
intéressait quoi il ya une solidarité
train my own qui n'est pas négligeable
on a notamment accueilli des familles de
réfugiés de migrants donc ça reste dans
une continuité où il ya vraiment ce
noyau solidaire ou autour de l'école
autour du noyau associatif justement on
met en avant met en valeur en cette
culture à la fois train bayonne mais
c'est aussi
qu'au delà des frontières le rythme
le chant est bien sûr la danse en
afrique tout cela est indissociable et
les enfants participent tour à tour à
chacun des ateliers
ensuite viendra le moment de la
curiosité et des questions copie comme
d'accord on fait ça souvent un poil et
aux cérémonies et les enfants à elles
sont vaincus mais pour des questions
vraiment qu'on les attendait pas du tout
à les employer une demande si on dort
dans des arbres mais en même temps on
comprend parce que voilà il ne
comprendre il ne connaît pas l'afrique
on aime bien de travailler avec les
enfants parce que il est vrai que nous
sommes des musiciens professionnels
nous notre vision il faut aller aussi
vers les enfants pour leur donner le
goût de ce qui se passe ailleurs
ailleurs cette fois ci c'était donc le
bénin d'où viennent ces huit merveilleux
musiciens et chanteurs
[Musique]
or le voir samedi et jabber